il agit nous sommes le 12 novembre 2009
il est 10 heures 30 le matin cette
journée là un homme de québec demande de
l'aide
après avoir retrouvé sa femme morte dans
le salon de son luxueux appartement
quelques mois
avec cet appel au 9-1-1 l'avis du juge
jacques delisle vient de basculer
de grands seigneurs de la cour d'appel
il va devenir un paria lui jadis sur un
homme craint et respecté mais froide et
arrogante certains mais pour sa famille
un homme chaleureux qu'ils aimaient
partir en croisière avec sa femme nicole
rainville avec qui il a vécu près de 50
heures c'est lui qu'on admirait mais
c'est elle qui tenait les rênes de la
famille une femme de tête tu as tous
ceux qui l'ont connu en apparence tout
allait bien et celle de lille jusqu'à ce
jour de 2007 madame rêve il a fait un
avc restant paralysée du côté droit
c'est une femme hyperactive qui
cuisinait kamehre savoir qu'ils avaient
un club de bridge
je dirais jamais arrêter du jour au
lendemain on y enlève tout seul jour au
lendemain subitement est paralysée a le
plus sa capacité de
de concentration à la grande difficulté
d'élocution
à la vue de sens à sa vie du tout du
tout l'avis de jacques delisle aussi a
changé
lui qui rêvait d'une retraite dorée
consacrer dorénavant toutes ses énergies
à s'occuper de sa femme devenue
handicapée
j'avais été vraiment impressionnés par
le dévouement le dévouement exemplaire
de sa femme
je n'ai même jamais jamais jamais jamais
que diable mais il ya eu la mort de ma
main ville en novembre 2009 on annoncé
au départ qu'il s'agissait de suicide
elle se serait tiré une balle dans la
tête avec le pistolet de chambéry là
sachant déprimé ces enfants et les
bruits du juge craignaient depuis
longtemps qu ils finissent par passer à
l'acte moi mais jamais directement je
veux en finir au may hamm a fini à lui
ont demandé si à bd si on peut trouver
des choses sur internet comme un suicide
et juge à la retraite de la cour d'appel
du québec est accusé du meurtre
prémédité de son épouse
mais la thèse du suicide n'a pas duré
longtemps sept mois plus tard en juin
2010 le juge delisle est arrêté par les
policiers à son appartement de sillery
le souvenir atroce pour des membres de
sa famille dont sa fille qui est avocate
paraît que j'ai hurlé nombreux mes
collègues mans par le camp
jamais on jamais on ne pensait jamais on
ne doutait jamais le procès qui a suivi
a été couvert en long et en large par
les médias au grand mécontentement du
juge et de sa famille
le dénuement de la sphère de l'est la
clé une immense honte de chaque coupable
de meurtre au premier degré a tranché le
jury qui lui non plus n'a pas cru à la
thèse du suicide
une condamnation confirmée par la cour
d'appel et par la suite par la cour
suprême qui a refusé d'entendre la cause
cet engagement c'est eux s'appelle bon
c'est sympa de bon sens a pas de morcenx
et comme il faut faut le vivre pour le
croire j'étais absolument et que l'étude
petite impasse aspect peau j'ai été très
très très chaud paix depuis sa
condamnation il ya trois ans jacques
delisle est incarcéré au pénitencier de
sainte-anne-des-plaines dans une section
à sécurité maximale c'est là que nous
l'avons rencontré c'est le genre de
personne qui a battu et humilié juge
delisle a décidé de témoigner
publiquement pour la première fois sur
ce qui s'est passé
cinq ans après la mort de sa femme en
espérant faire rouvrir sont aussi
il prétend avoir été victime d'une grave
erreur judiciaire
le jour de votre arrestation ce que
j'étais surpris vous vous étiez en dit
non mais non j'ai été surpris ils
étaient surpris sauf que ce pays ont en
main j'étais surpris a été surprise je
suis tombé en bas de ma chaise
l'ex juge delisle a aujourd'hui 79 ans
et va croupir en prison jusqu'à l'âge de
101 ans avant d'être admissible à une
libération conditionnelle
s'ils ne meurent pas avant les devenu la
honte la magistrature lui qui est le
premier juge de l'histoire canadienne
avoir été condamné pour meurtre au
premier degré la plus grave accusation
qui soit c'était dur quand vous êtes
rentré ici là où est au départ j'ai
connu des deux connus des petites
périodes difficiles pour un exemple
donné je me souviens les premières
journées c'était l'été je lisais dans je
me suis encore m fait cirer des pommes
mais de fait cirer des cailloux
mais avec le temps tu ça s'est estompé
parce que vous êtes juge c'est ça c'est
ça donc c est que juge
c'était et c'est ça suscite une certaine
réaction chez vos codétenus
ouais ouais ouais ouais et maintenant
les relations sont man avec mes
co-détenues on s'entend très bien
qu'est ce qui implique ficelles pour
vous ici c'est d'accepter d'être ici
l'ex juge delisle a toujours gardé le
silence sur les événements entourant la
mort de sa femme pourquoi vous avez
accepté de nous parler c'est la première
fois pour parler oui c'est la première
fois parce que je veux que les gens
sachent ce qui s'est réellement produit
ce motel
revenons donc aux événements dramatiques
du 12 novembre 2009 se sont déroulés
dans cet appartement
jacques delisle a gardé malgré sa
condamnation dans les minutes qui ont
suivi la mort de sa femme l'ex juge
delisle avait affirmé aux policiers et
s'était suicidé en se servant d'un
pistolet appartenant qu'il avait oublié
sur une table à l'entrée de son
appartement et qu'il avait laissé chargé
sa femme est d'être la marche est je
serais rendu à la table aurait pris
larmes le réel même chargé et serait
retourné sur son divin pour se tirer une
balle dans la tête pendant l'absence
d'une heure de son mari c'est à son
retour que monsieur de lille aurait
retrouvé son corps inanimé
cette première version avait suscité des
doutes de chez les policiers
surtout que les juges avaient eu un
comportement étrange en leur présence
pourquoi ne pas avoir collaborer
davantage avec la police parce que au
départ je n'ai pas aimé leur attitude à
mon égard dès le départ mais les
policiers ont vite soupçonné monsieur de
l'île de meurtre
lorsqu'ils ont découvert une tache noire
sur la main gauche de madame rainville
prenante ou canon du pistolet
comment expliquer la présence de cette
tâche sur la même mec nul armes puisque
l'autre était complètement parisé
rapidement les policiers conclu que la
tâche est apparu sur sa main dans un
geste d'autodéfense et que c'est
monsieur de lille qui a tiré sur sa
femme
plus tard les policiers découvrent que
monsieur de lille avait une maîtresse
son ex secrétaire et qu'un éventuel
divorce lui aurait coûté une somme de
près d'un million de milles dollars pour
aggraver les choses et policiers
finissent par apprendre que les deux
projetait de vivre ensemble mais ils
n'ont pas eu le temps de mettre leur
projet à exécution
sept mois après la mort de l'un dréville
les policiers se présente à
l'appartement de l'ex juge pour
l'arrêter ce une accusation de meurtre
au premier degré
cinq ans après la mort de sa femme jeudi
il a donc décidé d'expliquer ce qui est
arrivé ce qu'il n'a pas fait à son
procès il faisait prenait son petit
déjeuner loger eurent remarqué que
nicole n'avait mangé qu'elle est à
moitié elle un peu déprimé
nicole s'est levé en selve un job bien à
soi
il me faut de parler et leur nid calme a
dit jacques je n'en peux plus je veux le
pistolet quête à l'arrière lui dit
cherry ici ce qui se passe dit c'est pas
la seule nicole dans son école this et
plein de jeunes qui sont comme toile en
fauteuil roulant lui dis je lis même des
gens qu'on connaît les dons qu'elle vous
demande de lui fournir larrouy
qu'est ce que vous répondez à l'oeil
c'est un suivi très long un très long
dispute alors là je dis quand nicole
chizy je voudrais tu que j'appelle la
lie de nicole gzip à taichung mauvais
conseillers il donc essayé de la
dissuader à ce moment-là essayait de les
dissuader sur sa durée combien de temps
ça devrait durer une conversation sa
durée sur ma grosseur qu'elle revenait
avec ce désir d'en finir
oui plusieurs fois plusieurs fois donc
son désir était ferme à ce moment-là
vous ressentiez dans son désir était
ferme soyaux aucun doute j'essayais de
les dissuader
j'ai dit quand nicole on a fait des
croisières ne fait plusieurs cures
gernika les mois le site même après
qu'elles aient été paralysée vision
l'enfer dont jocks un brin nostalgique
faire des croisières
lundi d'avoir toutes ces belles femmes
sont habillées les gamins de soi puis
moi j'arrive avec ma prothèse jeune âge
je me sens malade
alors donc sa diction là se déroule
pendant à peu près unam oui et donc vous
comprenez ce que vous comprenez qu'elle
veut vraiment mettre fin à ses jours à
ce même seulement il ya aucun de tes
aucun doute dans mon esprit et on avait
déjà vu nicole et moi avant même son
arrivée ici le ca rien à voir on avait
déjà eu avec des ailes et moi puis avec
des amis des discussions sur le droit
d'une personne de mettre fin à ses jours
quand sa vie est misérable
donc après la discussion vous acceptez
vous faites quoi vous lui donnez le
revolver après la discussion
je suis allé chercher l'âme qui n'était
pas sur la table les mamies sur le haut
de la bibliothèque
un espèce de deux planches découvrait
est impossible de voir dont vous avez
été chercher chez arm
oui vous l'avez vous lui avez donné dans
ses mains mais c'est à dire j'allais
chercher leurs larmes étaient dans une
boîte de beretta dans une boîte à côte
dans la même boîte y avait le magasin
qui était sorti du pistolet et j'ai
inséré le mag avec trois balles dans le
magasin j'ai inséré le magasin dans
le pistolet j'ai chargé pistolet et j'ai
ramené tout ça à l'avant aux passants
devant le bureau produit d'entrée j'ai
déposé la boîte et j'ai mis le pistolet
sur la table en face de la ouni qu'elle
était assise et vous avez laissé un
pistolet ces données là j'ai s'est
réunie pendant mes bras et embrassé des
nikon choix pour toi j'ai pris ma
retraite pour précisément prendre soin
de toi un dc précisément ce genre que je
ne suis plus capable d'endurer la
dépendance a dit voudra bien de voir
jean rédélé le me place indice élevé du
matap n'est pas être capable de
planifier une journée de dépendre de
toujours de quelqu'un dont je suis et le
pont ça m'avait frappé l adie de n'être
pas soi-même et l'ombre de quelqu'un
dont vous le prenez dans vos boys et
vous partez oui en lui demandant de
réfléchir oui ce sont les derniers mots
et dernier mot que j'ai dit nicole
promets moi une chose s'il te plaît pas
mais moi de réfléchir avant posé son
geste elle vous dit quoi
les derniers mauvaise journée au
comédien jack
laisse moi tranquille laisse moi une
heure sont les derniers mots qu'elle
aime et s'ils sont les derniers mots
benzi bonjour à tout le monde
jacques delisle d'avoir quitté son
appartement vers 9h30
il a pris sa voiture pour se rendre près
de l'université laval et avoir mâché par
la suite
puis il est parti faire des courses une
caméra a capté son image
je verrai pas il en ouvrant la porte le
jeu vinicole sur le divin plein de ça
dont j'aimais les salades sur la table
tous pourris j'ai couru vers l'école me
suis agenouillé devant elle
là j'ai voulu me pencher et populeux
l'embrasser dans le visage de plaintes
sans label visage tourné vers le mur le
mur est
alors là je me suis penché j'ai voulu
mettre m'atteindre sur son sa poitrine
et là j'ai vu une douille sur la patate
j'ai chassé 7,2 ya et je me suis penché
bleus jeudi nicole nicholl nicholl j'ai
pleuré
fou
jacques delisle ni donc avoir de suite
sang-froid sa femme mais il avoue qu'il
l'a aidé à se suicider en chargeant son
pistolet ce qu'il était incapable de
faire et en le déposant près d'elle il
dit avoir caché la vérité non seulement
policiers mais aussi à ses enfants
justement faire entendre votre appel au
9-1-1 pour voir dans quel état d'esprit
vous étiez alors qu'est ce que vous
saviez que vous alliez pas tout dire le
nom j'étais sous le choc
d'ailleurs on on sent très vite par ma
voix que je suis sourd
dès le moment où vous avez téléphoné
vous n'aviez pas pris cette décision de
ne pas tout dire non non non seulement
jacques delisle n'a pas tout dit aux
policiers mais il leur a menti
il leur a dit que le pistolet se
trouvait dans cette petite boîte sur une
table à l'entrée d'appartements et non
pas comme ils l'affirment aujourd'hui il
avait déposé près de sa femme il l'avait
chargé comme étant le crime des deux
suicides
c'est un crime passible d'un maximum de
14 en prison d'ailleurs il n'a aussi
rien dit à ses enfants
ils regrettent aujourd'hui c'est aux
missions et ses mensonges
jean patou leblanc qu'une chose super
quad pour plusieurs raisons d'abord nous
et ils jugent faut que vous sachiez que
je n'ai pas de smic 1 dames demi de
personnes qui voient parler ou police il
n'a pas tué nicole alors je voyais pas
la nécessité de dévoiler ce qui s'était
passé parce que je doutais beaucoup de
la réaction à la fois de mes enfants et
de la réaction de mes proches de mes
amis pippo tête du monde en général
pas sûr que les gens sont encore prêts à
accepter une telle situation mais je
vous concède que c était stupide de ma
part
l'avocat de jacques delisle maître
jacques larochelle se doutait bien que
son client ne lui disait pas tout au
début des procédures judiciaires mais il
estime aujourd'hui que son mensonge
s'explique quand les policiers sont
arrivés et qu'il a raconté cette
histoire invraisemblable il le faisait
pour ne pas le dire à sa famille on dit
de cette invraisemblable que juges la
cour d'appel ne pose pas des actes un
peu étrange pas du tout et comme juge
vous deviez savoir que la vérité finit
toujours par nous rattraper les mérites
à rattraper parce que la vérité c'est
que j'ai un peu dessus et nicole mais à
ce moment là aucun missile en mai qu'un
juge sac est un peu difficile à
comprendre aux américains juge manteau
pas ici moins qu'un juge soit possession
d'une arme prohibée au museo monsieur le
set en ne les allées étaient 25 1 d'un
tiroir verrouillé de mon bureau je n'ai
jamais eu l'intention de m'en servir
faut quand même réalisé que j'étais pas
tout à fait moi même ce matin à dole
après la découverte du corps de nicole
j'aimerais ça vous voir à ma place se
trouvaient j'ai passé vingt deux
conjoints mais il a trouvé ensanglanté
sur
le sauf m charles levasseur et le
procureur qui a fait arrêter l'ex juge
de lille sous une accusation de meurtre
au premier degré mais ce n'est pas lui
qui a fait le procès nous lui avons
appris la version de monsieur de lille
aujourd'hui le juge dès lundi devant la
caméra que il a menti aux policiers
est ce que vous saviez ce à sa première
fois vous entendez ce vrai comment
voyage c'est que franchement surpris
très franchement je suis mainz raison
selon m levasseur le sort de l'ex juge
aurait peut-être des différents s'il
avait donné cette version policy dès le
début est ce que ça aurait changé le
portrait propulsion prônait le même
programme
probablement que ça aurait changé sarah
changer la proches sarah change
évidemment la théorie la poursuite c'est
clair oui ça aurait modifié certaines
choses
est-ce que chef d'accusation aurait été
différent c'est un hommage que pour vous
et il serait peut-être sorti aujourd'hui
probablement probablement
mais quand vous avez fait ce téléphone
quand vous avez quand vous avez retrouvé
votre femme est plus tard aussi vous
saviez vous êtes juge vous saviez que
aider quelqu'un comme ça ça peut être
criminelle objectivement d'également ses
dunks raide mais pour moi ce matin là
c'est pas à ce à quoi j'ai pensé ce
matin là je répondais ou cris coeur de
nicole de dans ma tête ça ne commettait
pas un acte d'une offense criminelle
malgré ces infirmations mettre le
masseur n'est pas ébranlée dans sa
conviction de la culpabilité de l'ex
juge de lille au niveau de la
crédibilité de cette affirmation leur
faut bien comprendre que le procès est
terminé
la cour d'appel s'est penché sur la
question la cour suprême s'est penché
sur la question et de le dire
aujourd'hui
à mon avis et c'est mon humble avis à
mon avis ça affecte la crédibilité de
cette affirmation le oui parce que parce
qu'elle est faite peut-être un peu tard
ce n'est que vers la fin du procès que
les membres de la famille de jacques
delisle ont été mises au courant de la
version de leur père lors d'une
rencontre avec m la rochelle
je n'étais pas content qu'on m'ait menti
oui c'est au contact
c'est comme si j'avais senti qu'on
m'avait pas fait confiance
même chose pour vous j'étais surpris
j'étais surpris de voir à quel point il
avait eu à avoir une geste tous les deux
mains et un kit est un de notre contrôle
j'espère avoir jamais à prendre une
décision comme cela c c c c ou ça peut
être très difficile
si cette version est vrai pourquoi le
juge delisle accueilli au pied du mur ne
l'a pas dit lors du procès lui qui a
refusé de témoigner à la surprise
générale une décision complètement
incompréhensible pour ceux qui ont suivi
le procès au départ il devait tout ça a
été annoncé par tous oui nous avons
réparé son témoignage d'amour passée
dessert après la raison des voyages
c'est évident qu'il devait témoigner à
ce moment là dimanche soir vers 8h30
là la conjointe de mon fils dominique
est venu me voir et elles m'ont supplié
de ne pas témoigner
elle me dit que ses propres enfants se
faisait agacé à l'école caisse il s'en
était déjà trop dit à mon égard de ne
pas ajouter encore ce que j'étais pour
dire que c'était affreux déjà pour la
famille de supporter tout ça la belle
fille de monsieur de lille ainsi que ses
deux enfants confirme son affirmation
c'est ce qu'on voyait les packs dans les
médias le lendemain
comment on allait expliquer à nous deux
petits-enfants qui grimpera avait aidé
gramat à s'enlever la vie et ont pensé
que j'en avais pas besoin d'en faire
plus aussi
on pensait vraiment que qu'avec ce
qu'invités plaidé puis prouvées en cour
qu'il ya les sentir et qui avait pas eu
de preuve hors de tout doute raisonnable
dominique marche on regrette aujourd'hui
cette intervention auprès de son beau
parce que maintenant que je vois le en
prison pour le reste de ses jours parce
qu'il n'a pas témoigné que je me dis si
j'avais pas été peut-être je vais pas eu
cette conversation là il aurait
certainement témoigner ce que je me sens
coupable
c'est ce que oui
c'est au lendemain de cette visite que
le juge delisle a informé son avocat
qu'il n'allait plus témoigné me rappelle
très bien de la voix altérée y avait la
voix que je sache et il était hagard il
était livide
il était vraiment méconnaissable
manifestement il n'avait pas dormi de la
nuit c'est ce qu'il m'a dit d'ailleurs
sa volonté de témoigner qu'ils étaient
vives jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à leur kit
et fat et sur laquelle je comptais pas
ce qu'il faut vouloir témoigner pour
bien témoigne sa volonté était
complètement disparu voulait plus
témoigner notre pour faire témoigner nos
clients défense c'est une c'est une
décision qui est extrêmement difficile à
prendre mais dans la tête de douze
personnes qui sont qui sont jurés et qui
en est qu'ils ont et à qui on donne un
cours de droit d'accélérer pour eux ces
gros bon sens pour eux ces gros bon sens
surtout sonnée juge surtout surtout sur
les jeux
c'est ici à toronto que le sort de l'ex
juge jacques delisle pourrait se jouer
dans les bureaux de james walker un
avocat réputé qui se spécialise dans la
défense de prisonniers injustement
condamnés qui ont épuisé tous les
recours
james blake eu à contribuer à faire
libérer une dizaine de cas célèbres au
canada donkey paul morin david milgaard
est il n'a pas hésité à épouser la cause
de l'ex juge de lille
je prends les causes de personnes que je
crois véritablement innocente et je
crois que monsieur de lille est
véritablement innocent
pour james blake eu ce qui saute aux
yeux dans la cause de lille ce sont les
erreurs des expertises notamment
balistiques pour appuyer la thèse du
meurtre
il a été condamné avec ce que je
considère de très mauvaises preuves
médico légales
c'est une cause fréquente de
condamnations injustifiées certainement
dans plusieurs des cas où j'étais
impliqué je crois que c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans ce cas-ci lors du procès deux
éléments clés ont fait l'objet d'
analyse minutieuse
premièrement la fameuses taches sur la
mer nicole rainville causés par la
poudre à canon provenant de la décharge
du pistolet deuxièmement l'angle de
pénétration de la balle dans la tête
pour les experts de la poursuite au
moment du tir le canon du pistolet est
en angle de 30 degrés par rapport à la
tempe de malandrins ville et les tâches
s'explique par un geste d'autodéfense
cette théorie a été testé et retester
dans le laboratoire de sciences
judiciaires et de médecine légale à
montréal
le pathologiste au dossier à évaluer
l'angle de tir à partir d'une
trajectoire de la balle d'un cerveau
sans déviation qui compatibles selon lui
avec les conclusions de tests
balistiques
le tout a été envoyée au chef de la
section balistique de la police de
marseille en france pour une contre
vérification il est venu à la même
conclusion
ce n'est pas un suicide c'est un meurtre
je pense que les experts du laboratoire
québécois qui ont témoigné pour la
couronne ont présenté une vue très
simpliste du doubs si ils n'ont
considéré aucun autre scénario que
l'hypothèse la plus facile pays si ce
n'est jacques donné les raisons propres
experts lors du procès vassilis russe
tout neuf un témoin expert français qu'à
mener ses propres études et qu'un est
venu à une toute autre conclusion
laval est rentré dans le cerveau à 90
degrés et non en angle à 30 degrés comme
le prétend la couronne il dit que la
trajectoire de la balle devient
imprévisible
dès qu'elles frappent un os avant son
entrée dans cerveau et que la cicatrice
à la tempe confirme l'angle
perpendiculaire
selon lui les tâches à la main
s'explique par le fait que nicolas
rainville aurait pris le pistolet à
l'envers et aurait tiré sur la gâchette
en utilisant son majeur
un scénario tout à fait compatible avec
le fait que sa main droite dominante
était paralysée et qu'il était
maladroite avec sa main gauche
selon jacques larochelle ses
explications aurait dû semer le doute
raisonnable pour que son client soit
acquitté la question de langue est
cruciale si on n'est pas en présence
d'un land la 30° si la poursuite ne peut
pas établir hors de tout doute que la
balle est entrée à un angle de 30 degrés
la thèse de la couronne s'effondre il ya
plus de condamnations possible alors la
question de langue qui paraît à première
vue un peu mais tu es métier qui est
artificiel ne l'est pas du tout c'est
une question de vie ou de mort selon m
la rochelle c'était le cas je dois
mettre la vache elles disent que c'était
le cas pourquoi ça vous fera sourire
lorsqu'on analyse la preuve de façon
isolée de façon chirurgicale
effectivement la balistique peut prendre
une importance qui est à mon avis est
démesuré mais lorsqu'on joue lorsqu'on
regarde l'ensemble du portrait il ya pas
je serai balistique là si on n'avait pas
juste la balistique il y avait d'autres
éléments
et pour cette raison là que ça m'a fait
sourire c'est que m la rochelle
s'échauffent mclaren faisait le coeur du
litige
d'ailleurs la cour d'appel a statué que
le jury n'avait pas agi de manière
déraisonnable en tenant compte de
l'ensemble de la preuve
avec mon collègue de l'émission de fêter
state de la sib ici nous avons fourni
toute la documentation à trois experts
dans trois villes différentes à
l'extérieur du québec
c'est la première fois qu'ils voient la
preuve le docteur peter marketing un
pathologiste médico légal à la retraite
de winnipeg penche de la couronne s'est
carrément trompé j'ai l'impression qu'il
y avait eu malentendu important entre le
pathologiste et le spécialiste en
balistique
je suis convaincu le résultat d'une
mauvaise interprétation des conclusions
du pathologiste l'avait dit lui que
l'angle de tir était à 30 degrés mais
rien ne prouve cette idée de langue est
restée dans l'imaginaire et la thèse de
la couronne commencé en dépendre de ses
doigts
c'est triste et c'est des deux pointus
marketing crois que si l'angle de tir
était à 30 degrés il y aurait eu des
traces de poudre autour de la blessure à
l'entrée de la balle ses cheveux aurait
été aussi il y aurait eu des fragments
de balles et des brûlures sur la peau
mais il n'y en avait pas l'expert en
balistique il y amène brakes pense aussi
que la couronne a erré pénis selon moi
la position du canon n'était pas à 30
degrés concernant le suicide assisté
je crois que dans le contexte du cas
actuel quelqu'un aurait dû se poser la
question
ce cas devrait être examiné à nouveau le
pathologiste michael schrunk partage à
vis des autres experts le pistolet était
perpendiculaire
la couronne s'est trompé il faudrait
revoir ce cas des trois utilise ont
essayé de reproduire le dépôt sur la
main avec cet angle de 30 degrés mais il
ne semble pas avoir obtenu le même
résultat il ne correspond pas à la
marque est réel d'autre part l'expert de
la défense qui a fait des tests avec
l'angle perpendiculaire basée sur un
certain positionnement de larmes dans la
main de la victime semble avoir pu
reproduire la tâche sur la main il ay ay
si un doute raisonnable
le n'zi monde gueule
ces trois experts sont convaincus que la
demande de révision de la preuve
technique présentée au jury est justifié
cette révision est nécessaire pour
écarter toute possibilité d'une erreur
judiciaire
mais cela n'ébranle pas celui qui si les
procédures pour faire 1 était jacques
delisle
moi je suis encore aujourd'hui
moralement convaincu que l'accusation
qui ont été portées par le juge de la
cour du québec et celle qui reflète la
trame factuelle qui a eu lieu à cette
date là donc que tirer sur sa femme
du fond de sa cellule l'ex juge delisle
ne comprend toujours pas pourquoi le
jury ne l'a pas acquitté avez vous
l'impression d'avoir été jugée plus
sévèrement parce que vous êtes si un jeu
je pense que oui djamel établir mais je
pense que vous savez où on n'a pas peur
d'un condamné un juge le fait d'avoir
été jugés ce que ça a joué contre lui ça
j'aurais tendance à lui donner ça
j'aurais tendance à lui donner peut-être
surtout dans le contexte où il a
prétendu sa probable la nage au contenu
l'ex juge delisle d'y croire encore à la
justice mais il remet en question le
système des jurys surtout dans le procès
de meurtre au premier degré est ce que
vous trouvez que donc une preuve
technique très complexe qui était
qu'elle en est faite devant jury deux
jours et demi de délibérations du jury
est ce que vous trouvez que le jury
était en mesure de bien comprendre les
choses
mais ce n'est pas facile mieux dire je
ne sais pas 1 ce qui s'est passé lors
des délibérations mais je suis un petit
peu renversé de voir que on a délibéré
que deux jours devant toute cette preuve
d' à l'esstic très technique sans
vouloir se prononcer sur la cause de son
ex collègue et ami qu'il visite
régulièrement en prison
l'ancien juge en chef de la cour d'appel
du québec pierre michaud va dans le même
sens
j'ai toujours été d'avis que les jurés
avaient beaucoup de difficulté à saisir
toutes les subtilités techniques dans
certains cas il ya peut-être des
dossiers ou c'est moi indiqué d'y aller
quand une preuve technique sur un
meurtre c'est inquiète way
le juge delisle en vue aussi aux médias
dans leur couverture du procès qui
aurait pu influencer selon lui les jurés
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas séquestré ses
dettes à mon avis d'une naïveté
déconcertante que de penser qu'un procès
qui va profiter pendant qu'un procès
durent cinq semaines y a personne qui
voit parler aux jurés sajoo et vous
pensez que nous envoyons non mais est ce
que vous vous pensez réellement que
pendant cinq semaines des jurés qui
retournent à la maison n'entendront
jamais parlé du procès ne lirons jamais
ce qui s'est écrit dans les journaux
rires non c'est des dunes et éviter
déconcertant même cinq ans après la mort
de sa femme
l'humiliation est le sentiment qui hante
le plus l'ex juge de lille même si j'ai
pas commis de près mais quand même
légalement je suis un criminel
est ce que c'est quelque chose dont des
enfants sont fiers que d'avoir un père
qui a été reconnu criminellement
responsable d'un meurtre au premier
degré mais mes petits enfants
il se faisait à agacer l'école temps
grand-papa dessus est un grand moment
comment voulez vous supporter ça ça vous
affecte encore ah oui jacques delisle a
mal accepté d'avoir vu sa vie privée
étalée sur la place publique notamment
sa relation avec sa maîtresse qui datait
de quelques années johan clamons dont
son ancienne secrétaire avec qui ils
planifiaient aller vivre cette relation
extra conjugale et tous les éléments de
la preuve circonstancielle
un juge qui a une arme prohibée un juge
qui ne collaborent pas avec les
policiers une dame qui donc votre femme
qui se tire une balle dans la tête ce
qui arrive pas souvent chez les femmes
semble-t-il pas de lettre d'adieu et par
la suite la découverte de votre relation
avec votre ancien secrétaire et la
filature sur vous tout ça ensemble
est-ce que ça se comprend pas d'une
certaine façon que content qu'on ait
décidé de vous arrêter au mieux qu'au
grand show dans tout ce monsieur je peux
sûrement pas le seul homme au québec qui
a eu une relation extramaritale bon
jamais jamais nicole jamet nicole puis
j'aimais madame plamandon mais cela n'en
fait pas pour autant un meurtrier
saluons mais tous ensemble oui le fait
de ne pas collaborer encore là vous
aviez s'attarde pas que la boirie comme
je vous dis si on m'avait appelé le
temps de me permettre de retomber sur
mes pis on m'avait appelé une semaine
quinze jours après et patrick ya aucun
doute que j'aurais dit certainement
monsieur vous allez vous dire ce qui
s'est passé pour la famille de l'ex juge
l'atmosphère autour du procès à québec a
joué un grand rôle dans sa condamnation
on s'attend pas
c'était la cei midi et soir dans tout
les médias à toutes les poses à radio
dans toute l'île pozer tv sur tout les
médias sociaux synthé comme ça pendant
des mois et des mois et des mois
sako arrêté ouf
mais le plus blessant dans cette
histoire pour l'ex juge de lille c'est
la décision de la cour d'appel de
maintenir le verdict de culpabilité
ça court où il a siégé pendant 17 ans
mais là aussi dit-il le show viennent
des erreurs judiciaires comme celle dont
a été victime
les gens aiment un homme de mont laurier
est justement condamné à 15 ans prison
définitivement de l'incompréhension à
l'égard de l'arrêt de la cour d'appel
sur je n'en reviens pas je suis mais ils
vont mâcon salle se dire je les
comprends jusqu'à un certain point
parce que moi même à la cour d'appel
vous vous donnez un corps bien
spécifique monsieur heinz je me suis
trompé je peux aussi vous mieux coûté
une journée mais je lui demande pardon
les deux avocats de l'ex juge delisle
savent que leur client joue sa dernière
carte et que la bataille est loin d'être
gagnée d'avancé
c'est un grand défi c'est toujours un
grand défi ces cas ne sont jamais
faciles
vous luttez contre une présomption de
culpabilité il a été reconnu coupable
par un jury et ses appels ont été
rejetés
vous vous battez contre une présomption
de culpabilité en vigueur je crois
absolument totalement sans réserve sans
limite à son innocence je suis convaincu
que c'est une erreur judiciaire
en attendant les membres de la famille
de lille qui habite québec
je relaie chaque mois pour aller le
visiter à sainte anne des plaines
c'est un cauchemar c'est sûr cela pas de
mots saint léger je sens que ça suffit
ce mais on est ici pour retrouver cette
journée là on a perdu notre mère qu'on a
perdu notre part l'eau on peut le sauver
c'est que ces deux recours de la
dernière chance mais ont perfé sport
parce que moi j'ai toujours je me suis
toujours dit tant qu'il l'espère yeux de
la vie que je pense que mon père c'est
le même ce qu'il tient en vie
sinon il serait plus lourd c'est ce qui
tient en tic
même si le ministre a accepté de rouvrir
le dossier de l'île de nombreuses
questions subsisterait quand même
surtout d'avoir attendu si longtemps
avant de donner sa version
les gens qui vont regarder cette
entrevue oui ils vont se dire il
pourrait se dire oh mais c'est facile il
était condamné à la prison à vie
25 ans minimum et aujourd'hui ils
viennent ils acceptent de témoigner
aujourd'hui pour essayer d'amoindrir sa
peine
vous savez que les gens prédire sa
poudre aux yeux pas de contrôle sur ce
que les gens peuvent penser ou dire mais
sauf que moi je vous dis la vérité vous
dise welmant ce qui s'est passé et il
est à peu près temps que je le dise
parce que veut voir la lumière au bout
du tunnel je veux que le que le
cauchemar que je vis depuis près de
trois ans un moment donné